[Music]
[Applause]
hello I'm the Nostalgia guy remember it
so you don't have to I'm gonna talk
about the GI Joe movie
[Music]
yeah there's no current ayan nobody asks
for it I don't really have any reason I
just want to talk about this awesome
1987 cinematic nonsense is that so wrong
no Joe based on the popular army toy
line turn later into a hit 80s cartoon
GI Joe followed the adventures of Duke
and his team of soldiers fighting the
terrorist organisation Cobra
you know when terrorists were snakes I
miss snake terrorists as their
popularity grew more and more even to
the point of recruiting wrestlers into
their lineup sergeant slaughter here and
it does me proud to be part of the GI
Joe g4 1986 680 shit you are always GI
Joe they've decided to go to the big
screen with GI Joe of the movie it was
basically Team America for kids so no
swearing your face shitting but just as
much merkel is it everything you'd
expect it to be hell yeah good going on
hell yeah this is GI Joe the movie it
opens with what I can only describe as
the most American leave island intro a
kid's film could throw at you the Statue
of Liberty is under attack because
crashing through this guy comes a
fearful cry of Cobra and if you doubt
that the eighties sing it
[Music]
[Applause]
I love that one guy I could wink over in
the background but he got lost him the
group and is trying to call for him
[Music]
[Applause]
set them to g-rated head
oh my god this is way too much America
to take in for only one minute I need to
calm down with some Canadian okay
continue look at this it's the most
amazing opening ever everybody is
shooting everybody's flying with fire
and all around Lady Liberty while
eighties theme song plays
[Music]
if the American why I could lift a tank
and eat well let's visit the movie it
would do it in the animation is
spectacular every moment leaping off the
screen in a blaze of glory this is the
kind of military porn Michael Bay wishes
he could make you know instead of caught
in omage sir what the hell up and play
my jam
oh and you think CGI tobey maguire
posing in front of the American flag is
iconic pussy pansy piss we do picking up
the American flag rocket packing it to
the sky following him all the way up the
Statue of Liberty and planting it on her
head with his team while cheering to
their 80s theme song all you need is a
trump tweet saying he doesn't like it
and it'll be the most American thing in
the world
[Music]
Amerika Amerika indeed I'm the Nostalgia
Critic I remember so you don't have to
that's sorry it totally could stop there
and I would have been 100% satisfied the
film opens with the evil Cobra as the
metal face Cobra Commander is being
taught to by the head of Cobra serpent
oh I so miss snake terrorists it looks
like a Python choking on Archer now
what's what this makes on his side is it
like one snake human centipede together
I have so many questions about these
fashion choices so for those unfamiliar
there's nothing wrong with your computer
that is what he actually sounds like and
yes you're allowed to laugh at at all
you want we have four years Cobra
Commander looks for people to back up
his claims of serpent doors and
confidence but they stab him in the back
but someone breaks into Cobra
headquarters a deadly snake knockoff of
Sheba known as Python oh can we just
call these people what they are snake
Thundercats she shows them a powerful
device known as the broadcast energy
transmitter a device GI Joe has that can
transmit pure energy anywhere in the
world well let's find out if we've
wasted a billion taxpayer dollars this
country now seeing how Python this shows
where it is
Cobra attacks trying to get their hands
act what will croc watch in Suicide
Squad now
[Music]
you know I think everyone just needs a
random Tober commander line generator
app Serpentor does that thing James Earl
Jones did and Conan the Barbarian
forgetting like snakes he sure does
abuse him a lot but he gets launched
into the device and knocked out they
chase after Cobra but they're attacked
by henchmen from the tick and are
defeated
Cobra Commander recognizes Python and
panics they bring him back though and
python is now in command demanding Cobra
get serpent Oh back but the Joe's are
concerned where their search team went
so they're ready to send their new
recruits out into the field and until
they graduate the sooner they can fight
oh no they're gonna pull a transformers
movie out of this aren't they they're
gonna get rid of half the cat so they
can introduce new characters so god help
you if you destroy sergeant slaughter
maybe I'm jumping to conclusions maybe
they're just extras for the mission noob
those are action figures just put their
prices next to them right now where is
that gold-plated to fall lieutenant
Falcon get to know you the more I like
you the more of killing the original
Joe's something this franchise does very
well it looks like Lieutenant Falcon
played by Nash Bridges himself Don
Johnson is having trouble leaving his
Miami Vice days behind him as he sneaks
in a girlfriend to top secret areas
didn't it occur to you that a military
prison is no place for a date I'll take
the lady elsewhere sir come on babe this
is starting to get boring oh come on
it's not like she's a Cobra agent trying
to get top-secret information she's all
those things isn't she well this is why
we have rules nice legs for a grease
monkey soldier oh god I want me to kiss
it and make it better
oh yeah pick your lawsuit there are at
least three offenses in there a Cobra
breaks in through the magic of ironic
dialogue suppose our mythical
intruders did make it into serpent or
cellblock they'd still have to blast
through a couple of yards a super hard
concrete then that have to get past
three of our best guys and they help
serpent our escape Falcon of you
deserted your post you're confined to
quarters until court martials oh that
poor groping man and it's here that GI
Joe for a lack of a better way of
putting it gets a little silly serpent
Dodds taken to his true creator a
subterranean reptile man known as co-op
ulis voiced by burgess meredith i have
to say for a man that played the penguin
the world's oldest elf and a fly he once
again gives ten times more than what's
required for a bat shit crazy roll i
implanted the idea and the skill and
doctor Mindbenders rather pedestrian
brain which is a motivator is our
greater destiny which concerns me now
taking the king of the reptile people so
seriously even the mention of his name
warrants an oscar nomination
know that I am Columbus you see almost
laugh at that and I did I can play Jar
Jar Binks and I'd be amazing Falcon is
about to be thrown out of the Joe's but
Duke being his half-brother pleads with
them to keep him around Falcon shows his
appreciation I don't need your help
anymore Duke like a total jackass
Falcon Duke's trying to help by busting
my chops every chance he gets
I mean constantly being told what to do
you treat me like I'm in the military
he's sent to what they call the
slaughterhouse while Cobra Commander is
being Cobra court-martialed himself
being told pretty much out of nowhere
the history of the reptile people for
2,000 years ago the glory of Cobra la
dominated this planet but an age of ice
he was a fast Ice Age of destruction I
guess most are mankind took over leaving
only a few reptile people left and
co-commander being one of the reptile
people becoming disfigured in a science
accident nevertheless he was put in
charge of destroy mankind but he failed
so he's given us four that distorts him
even more it's not like giving ugly
glasses to the Elephant Man I think he's
kind of used to it thus he's thrown in
prison with the captured Joe's but not
before he calls him a fool I have no
reason to bring that up I just love
hearing and say it yourself well that's
going on Falcon is thrown into a
punishment camp for misbehaving Joe's
ran by slot the only guy aside from
burgess meredith who can make everything
sound awesome look at this human has to
say the line in DB dee dee dee bag and
by god he makes it sound amazing oh you
feel like a man on a ditty bag an
itty-bitty bank there's only so many
lines I can program as ringtones one of
the Joe's escapes Cobra la but gets
blinded so Cobra Commander has to lead
the way out wonderful direction thanks
GPS commander loses his faceplate
revealing honestly exactly what you
would imagine his face would look like
come on I'll sing for you
[Applause]
meanwhile slaughters men are called in
to infiltrate Cobras forces think of it
as an extra ruff training exercise and
why don't we leave our weapons behind
and make it really educational
well that's what I call a challenge no
weapons well that makes a lot of sense
next we're gonna play darts with no
darts dying just builds character
[Applause]
[Music]
you
they break inside and tried to contact
GI Joe through Cobras radio come in GI
Joe okay it's that a toy microphone or
the tap you pull for Cobra beer Falcon
gets capture though and is questioned
know many in your force what is the
purpose of your mission forever I think
I guessed your weak ass slaps he kind of
Ken but the other Joe save him and blow
up the base resulting in a big battle
between the two armies is that the new
battle cry okay Yoji the reptilian
technology is too much for them as
serpent Dora calls out to the reptilian
people I wish I was a fly on a wall when
that was being recorded the flying shit
am I saying
a giant snake monster Rises honestly
making me wonder why none of these
things were ever used in the past we
don't be singing trust in me if they use
these things from day one as serpent
Dora summons them via warrior princess
sound again just what I think that can't
get any funnier he goes total
high-pitched scream on the last one it's
like Homer Simpson scream took over at
the end
to trust a safe Falcon from serpent door
who wants him to see how cynic like you
can be we're still getting over Optimus
Prime you a-holes they steal the BT and
Duke uses his final words to say goodbye
promise me I'll make you proud you'll
see you will be missed
he's gone into a coma what he's gone
into a coma you a doctor now
what would even a doctor know that is
that the science of snake spears that
stab you through the heart have you done
a lot of research on this please tell me
what level of pissed off I'm supposed to
be actually fun fag Duke was supposed to
die but after the backlash of Optimus
Prime getting killed in the transformers
movie they backed out and threw in the
totally nonsensical line about him going
into a coma notice how you didn't see
anyone's lips move when that was said
he's got into a car it makes no sense
but Duke is still alive sucking out like
90% of the emotion we're supposed to be
feeling here too he's probably coming
back to who
[Music]
yo joseon next season yo qu Tober plans
to use the b ET to launch pots they'll
turn the world into reptile folk but Jo
seems to have located them Hawk I've
identified that energy sauce did he say
energy sauce I've identified that energy
sauce it's right next to the energy
muster and the energy relish meanwhile
flint and cobra commander find the other
Joe's and they tried to help them stop
Cobras evil attack Metroid and Nausicaa
tourist traps tried to stop him but they
approached the you know what if the
eighties for all we know this could have
been the first portal on this guy he's
in a coma
I really feel we should make that clear
one of the Joe's fights Python a
blindfolded because she'll make less
freakazoid jokes and surprisingly she
ends up winning oh my god come on Falcon
show me your moves oh my god that was
totally unintentional but seriously
though you're going to die
[Music]
ah how dare you g-rated me even though
somehow this was okay that was magic
going into coma juice Falcon stuffs the
B et Yin uses it to fry the pause as
well as Cobras headquarters great news
Duke's come out of his coma then doc
says Dukes gonna be a-ok and in other
news Pucci went back to his home planet
look at the sky the last of the mutation
spores are burning up in orbit thanks
big brother who is in a coma is no
longer in a coma and has no spiritual
connections whatsoever back so that was
GI jello the movie it gives exactly what
GI Joe the movie would give a ton of
action a ton of great animation a ton of
badass moments and a buttload of
corniness it is so ridiculous and
over-the-top but that's part of the fun
how aggressively American can a cartoon
be about the military while also being
for kids it's great 80s cheese for any
GI Joe fan so give it a watch and enjoy
a Real American Hero I'm the Nostalgia
Critic
[Music]
[Applause]
an itty-bitty ditty bag
you
hello the Walker here doing the charity
shout out and this week we are doing the
Alzheimer's Association the Alzheimer's
Association works on a global national
and local level to provide care and
support for all those affected by
Alzheimer's and other dementia zhh as
the largest nonprofit funder of
Alzheimer's research the Association is
committed to accelerating the global
process of new treatments Prevention's
and ultimately a cure the Association is
the leading voice for Alzheimer's
disease efficacy fighting for critical
Alzheimer's research prevention and care
initiatives at the state and federal
levels they diligently work to make
Alzheimer's a national priority founded
in 1980 by a group of family caregivers
and individuals invested in research
today they reach millions of people
affected by Alzheimer's across the globe
through their headquarters in Chicago a
public policy office in Washington DC
and a presence in communities across the
country they strive to make Alzheimer's
a thing of the past if you look at their
site in their YouTube channel you can
witness all the lives they've made
better trying their hardest to live in a
world without this disease click on the
link together we can change the future
of Alzheimer's
[Music]
you